that's effective
okay so what I want to do in today's
lecture is talk about the issue we've
already encountered the idea that
contextual tea is not an all for nothing
thing there's a we saw a qualitative
hierarchy of degrees of contextual tea
in in previous lectures with the notion
of strong contextuality at the top but
what I want to do in this lecture is
look at the idea of quantifying
contextual tea assigning a numerical
measure to it which is a natural thing
to do but in particular is important if
we want for example to calibrate the
advantage the quantum advantage the the
non classical advantage we may get in in
the kind of situations we've been
discussing in terms of how much
contextual tea is present in the system
so we need a suitable way of measuring
contextual tea to do that so this is a
joint work with bruit who's here and
shane mansfield and actually we're just
writing up a paper and actually we're
currently discussing whether one of the
equations of the paper is correct so
that caused a bit of a sleepless night
but that doesn't affect the the sort of
story to any great extent but it would
be nice to resolve it anyway so the the
general motivation we have a unified I
mean just to recap a little we have some
general framework for discussing
contextual tea we've already seen this
qualitative hierarchy and we want to
look at the quantitative measure and
there and as I said there are various
motivations for this contextual tea as a
resource we want also in general to be
able to compare between different
empirical models to see how much
contextuality is present in one as
against another and a particularly
important point as we saw we have a
notion of measurement scenario we
sort of gives the the sort of signature
of a particular situation a particular
setup alig ously to a vocabulary or a
schema in logical or database situations
and what we'd like to do is to be able
to compare degree of contextual 'ti
across different measurement scenarios
to have a sort of universal measure
that's generally applicable okay so I'm
just now recapping a bit on things we've
already seen I mean the the may be
tedious by repetition by now at least
hopefully this will this will be very
familiar so we have these tables
reflecting this kind of observational
scenario and the general setting that we
have is a measurement scenario which is
a set of measurements the set of maximal
contexts the the measure that the
measurements that can be performed
together or the variables that can be
evaluated together and a set of outcomes
of values that they can take which for
simplicity we take to be a single a
single set and we had this way of
portraying this situation
diagrammatically with the base space of
the variables and then they would we'd
have well edges just here in this low
dimensional case and generally a
simplicial complex telling us which
things are measurable together and then
above each base variable the fiber can
with the values it can take and we we
indicate which which outcomes are
possible together so we get a natural
kind of fibered structure and so here is
the triangle which we've already seen
some manifestations of so you see this
is not a bell scenario we can't separate
out Alice and Bob and Charlie and two
discrete agents but they they overlap in
this way and
obviously we have this impossibility of
having a global assignment of of colors
that a value 0 or one that meets the
meets the constraints given by the table
so and as we also saw I mean obviously
the generality of the definition
encompasses some intricate situations
this particular example is one of the
standard examples of a Cochin spec of
paradox and I'll say something about
those kind of arguments since they they
have roots in in logic in the sense
coach and inspector both being logicians
in the lecture tomorrow this is an
example we can construct in r4 and the
idea is we can label each of these
letters with vectors in the way that
Simona was describing in his talk
yesterday in such a way that the vectors
in each column form an orthonormal basis
in r4 and one can make an argument again
that again there's a certain with some
colouring constraints there can be no
global assignment that satisfies all of
these and yet these will correspond to
quantum measurements in fact the
strength of this kind of argument is
that it can show contextuality in a
state independent fashion the mere
structure of the measurements is
sufficient to guarantee that whatever
states you use you will see a
manifestation of contextual T so we'll
say more about that tomorrow so the the
idea of an empirical model then sits on
timing so it's the structure that
corresponds to the the kind of signature
given by the scenario so it's a family
of probability distributions on the
possible assignments two variables one
for each context and then we have this
local consistency condition this
compatibility condition which can be
expressed as a kind of conditional
independence assumption so the idea is
that the the local statistics that Alice
sees performing a given measurement is
independent of which choice of
measurement Bob makes otherwise Alice
could
make an inference about what Bob was
doing that would violate causality
constraints coming from relativity and
we saw various ways of understanding
this local consistency so in the diagram
it was this business of being able to
prolong paths and then the the sort of
global consistency which which would be
the hallmark of non contextuality in
which and the failure of which shows us
that we have contextuality is being able
to make an assignment to all the
variables that meets all the constraints
and we concern that we can and so it's
really telling us that the classical
data arises from determine from some
probabilistic mixture of deterministic
assignments this is essentially the idea
of the classical source as we described
it writ large
so here
so contexture allottee is present if we
can if we can I mean and other way of
saying it is if we can decompose the
data we see in the table into a convex
mixture of a probabilistic mixture of
deterministic assignments and if that's
not possible then we say the contextual
T is present and this is another way of
saying that we get don't have a hidden
variable model okay then we distinguish
this qualitative hierarchy and at the
top was the idea of strong contextuality
that so we saw that one one way of sort
of visually seeing the presence of
contextual T and the diagrams is that
every local assignment every edge could
be extended to a path which sort of went
round and finished back where it had
started assigning a unique value to each
to each variable and this is exactly
this idea that somewhere in the support
of this distribution there's some
assignment that accounts for every local
observation the global assignment that
accounts for every local observation
that we can make and so if it fails
somewhere then we already have this
intermediate level of contextual T what
we call logical contextuality
exemplified by the Hardy paradox but the
strongest form is where no local
assignment can be extended to a global
one and this is what we call strong
contextual tree and this was exemplified
by the P R box which as we know it goes
beyond so here it is it goes beyond
quantum mechanics but there are lots of
examples that do arise in the quantum
realm th said state and these coach and
speckle models which we'll discuss
tomorrow but it's very clear in the
picture of the P R box how we cannot
find any such path as we saw it's quite
linked to traditional logical paradoxes
ok so that was a brief recap now we want
to come to the issue of how we would
if I contextual tea to say meaningfully
how contextual of model is now there's
no claim that there's only one way of
doing it the nature of things with
measures is that there can be more than
one but the one that we're studying is
particularly natural and as we'll see
there's a lot of ways in which it has
good properties so the the basic idea is
this what we want to do given an
empirical model is see how far we can
make it contextual so one way of
expressing that is to write it as to see
how we can write it as a convex
combination a mixture of a non
contextual model and a strongly
contextual model by the way one thing I
haven't said and should have done is
that there's a characterization of
strong control okay let me say right now
that there's a characterization of
strong contextuality
which is that there's no such
non-trivial decomposition so it's
maximally contextual in the sense that
you can't break off any piece of it and
express it as a non contextual model so
that's fairly evident from the idea that
no piece of local data could be
explained by global assignment so the
support of any hypothetical distribution
on global assignments classical source
in other words that could account for
the data actually has to be empty and
that's saying that a decomposition like
this will be trivial where all the
weight is put on the strongly contextual
component on the other hand if the model
is non contextual we could make lambda 1
and then this part will be 0 so those
are the extremal cases what we're saying
is for any any empirical model there is
we can we can find convex decompositions
of this kind there's a maximum possible
value for this lambda which is attained
and this we call the non contextual
fraction of the model and its complement
is then the contextual fraction so
therefore this is a number that is that
always lies in the unit interval it's
it's this the model is non contextual if
and only if this contextual fraction is
0 and it's strongly contextual if and
only if the contextual fraction is 1 so
we're shortly gonna see how we obtain
and and the other good point is that
this number can be efficiently computed
given the empirical model so how do we
compute it well
there's we can set up a linear system
based on the the syntax of the
measurements in rem so we have a matrix
0 1 matrix which is just obtained from
the structure of this measurement
scenario so the row space is indexed by
the the local sections the context and
then the assignments of values to the
variables in the context and the column
space is indexed by the global
assignments the things which assign
values to all the variables and then we
put a 1 in an entry in the matrix in
those places where when you take the
global assignment in the column its
restriction to the context corresponding
to the row gives us that local section
and 0 otherwise so in fact the columns
of the matrix correspond to the
deterministic non contextual model and
as we've said every non contextual model
is equivalent to a mixture of
deterministic ones so a probability
distribution on mixtures of these models
is just given by a column vector of
probabilities
one for each global assignment and
similarly an empirical model one of
these things be written as a table 2d
table if we flatten it out into a vector
as we've already discussed so for
example the bail table flattens out like
this then it's a vector and a suitably
high dimensional real vector space
okay so now the question of how do we
how do we tell firstly whether an
empirical model is contextual or not a
yes-or-no question this is given
directly in these terms by the following
linear program so here's the here's the
empirical model flattened out as a
vector here's this incidence matrix and
as we've said the columns of the
incidence matrix correspond to the the
non contextual deterministic models so
we're asking for a vector of weights of
probabilities which such that and then
and the point is the way this has been
defined what this gives us when we
multiply this by such a such a vector of
weights is going to be probabilities
corresponding to the the entries in our
in the table for our empirical model so
if we recover the in the empirical model
as a vector of as a vector of
probabilities in this way by multiplying
this incidence matrix by this D then D
is a witness for them for the non
contextual T of the marble and so what
we're asking is to find such a D
satisfying these equations and obviously
it has to be non-negative incidentally
normalization takes care of itself
because this thing already is a sort of
a concatenation of probability
distributions so so it turns out that
it's automatic that not only will this
be non-negative
but it will be normalized and give us a
proper probability distribution over the
global assignments so this is a simple
linear system without whether the
constraint is or it is a linear program
that tells us whether or not a model is
contextual and what we simply do is to
relax it in order to get a way of
computing this non contextual fraction
so we just relax it in this way
otherwise everything stays the same and
of course we try and maximize this
quantity so we're looking for the
largest sub distribution lying at every
point below the actual probabilities in
the empirical model which sits in the
way which sits inside it in this way so
this natural relaxation exactly computes
the the non contextual fraction so that
the quantity that we're maximizing is
the total weight of this sub
distribution okay so so that's all well
and good but of course to assess this or
any such measure we need to see how it
relates to some of the other things
we've been talking about and one of the
compelling arguments that says this is a
very natural measure comes we relate
citria when we can when we related to
Bell inequalities and specifically
violations of Bell inequalities so let's
take a general perspective on what Bell
inequalities are for for a completely
general scenario so a bell in the so the
idea is it's it's it's some linear
constraints an inequality with with with
linear from a linear combination of the
probabilities in the in the table in the
empirical model so it's given by a
vector of real coefficients one for each
local section in the model and a bound
and we say that an empirical model
satisfies the inequality if the if the
inner product between if that linear
combination with those coefficients of
all the probabilities in the table
satisfies the given boundary forward
notion of what an inequality is and
without loss of generality we can take
the bound to be non-negative in fact we
can take it to be zero and that's a
useful convention to adopt
we say that so that's just an inequality
that may or may not be satisfied by some
given empirical model we say that it's a
bell inequality if it is actually
satisfied by every non contextual model
so that's what we mean abstractly by a
bell inequality is any linear
combination of the probabilities say
below some fixed bound which is
satisfied by every non contextual model
and we say that it's tight so it's going
to define a facet of the non contextual
polytope if it's saturated by some non
contextual model if the bound is
actually achieved by some non contextual
model okay so
so we have Bell inequalities and what
we'd want to do now is talk about the
extent to which they may be violated by
some non contextual model because that
will be a quantitative witness of
contextual 'ti so there's a there's a
bound we can make for no signaling
models for how big the inequality how
big this linear combination can be it's
a sort of easily derived bound the point
is that what we want to do is I mean we
could just say well if it exceeds the
bound we just look at and how much more
than the bound it is the trouble with
that is that it will it will be highly
specific to the scenario that we're in
if we if we introduce more measurements
and more opportunities for making the
number bit more context and therefore
more opportunities for making them
bigger it could we could we could get
huge numbers for the violation but they
wouldn't necessarily be very meaningful
so what we want to do is to have a
normalized measure of viola of a
violation of Bell inequalities which is
meaningful across scenarios in which we
can use to compare meaningfully with
this contextual fracture which remembers
itself already normalized since it lies
within the unit interval and the way we
do that is as follows we sort of factor
out as it were something that takes into
account the size of the scenario which
is this thing here which sums over all
the contexts in the scenario and just
looks at the maximum values of the the
coefficients with the for each among
among those for each context and we so
we so we normalized relative to that in
other words if I tell you I got thirty
barks in an exam you'll be impressed if
the examples out of thirty but less so
if it was out of a hundred so that's
what we're doing here and this will
indeed lie within the within the unit
interval okay so now we've normalized
the violation we have the following
result firstly the contextual fraction
bounds this normalized violation by
any empirical model of any Bell
inequality so it's at most diskette this
contextual fraction of the model
moreover there exists a specific Bell
inequality which again can be computed
efficiently for which this bound is
attained and in fact this inequality is
tight in this convex decomposition I
should say by the way that obviously we
got this we got this we computed this
can this contextual fraction by this
linear program so of course the the the
solution vector is not unique from this
from this linear program the quantity
that's being maximized is unique but not
the vector and so when we get this
decomposition into a non contextual part
and a strongly contextual part these
things are not unique but the values of
these things these measures of non
contexture allottee or contextual 'ti
are unique so what we're saying is that
for any such decomposition maximal
decomposition they spell inequality that
we will compute is tight for the non
contextual part okay and in fact the the
way we're going to get it is is by
duality of linear programming from the
linear program we already had to compute
the contextual fraction so here is that
program if we take the dual linear
program then we could just write this
down it's actually useful I mean we
could just do a transformation to the
solution of this but it's instructive to
make a substitution in this and then to
get a linear program here for computing
this bail-in ik what this witnessing
bell inequality which is perhaps more
informative as something that the the
vector that we compute here will be the
vector of coefficients for the Bell
inequality here's the bound of zero that
we've taken as a standard value for the
zero and and this can be fair
readily seen to give us the thing
involved specifically using the relation
given by the strong duality theorem of
linear programming between a solution of
a program and its dual one can show that
this gives us exactly an inequality
meeting the meeting the assertions of
the theorem so here descripton oh yes so
remember this was the scenario so it's
the set of the hyper graph that the
family of sets and then the salient
parameter here is how many contexts so
each of those sets we call a context and
the the salient parameter is how big the
thing is in terms of the cardinality of
this hyper graph of the other bubblers
of a number of sets so that's what what
that because if you remember that
entered into the normalizing factor here
so I mean well the the I mean we're
summing over all the contexts it so it
turns out that when you sort of work
through it the the actual number of
contexts is the is the thing that
controls how big things again by
dividing out through with this
normalization factor we're removing a
dependence on the sort of size of the
scenario and getting a better measure
for the for the contextual ality okay so
that's that's so this thing computes a
tight Bell inequality
okay so right so we as we've seen we can
apply to any measurement scenario it's
normalized so we can compare across
scenarios and it relates to the extremal
cases of non contextuality and strong
contextuality okay so let me just
briefly mention that since these things
can be computed and we have lots of
interesting examples arising from
quantum mechanics and elsewhere that it
can be quite instructive to compute them
so I'll just mention that so we've
played around a bit we're doing
computations and ruie and Shane have
developed a nice set of Mathematica
packages to which can do things like
calculating empirical models defined by
quantum states and measurements
calculating the incidence matrix which
is this combinatorial object we derive
from the measurement scenario that sets
up our linear system and then actually
using linear programming to compute
these quantitative measures of
contextual T and then also finding the
relative the witnessing bell
inequalities so we've already looked at
the Bloch sphere so we can think having
often measurements are taken on the
equatorial plane of the Bloch sphere
sometimes on the north-south plane but
this this is and one can then go through
a range of parameter values and plot
these so this is we're taking the Bell
State and we're plotting against a
family of values for the measurement
angles so it gives and we can see where
the Maxima and those Maxima actually
achieve the maximum the known maximum
Quantum violation of the CHS H
inequalities sir awesome found on the
maximal violation so it's sort of like
fun to do this we haven't looked
explicitly at the gh said state remember
the gh said state is a quantum state
that witnesses
strong contextuality so it's like the
it's like the bell state but but in with
larger numbers of parties so it's the
the mixed it's the it's the combination
of either all spin up or all spin down
so it's a kind of maximally entangled in
part I'd state and then we can consider
well the the the standard discussion
considers just X&Y measurements in the
equatorial plane to provide logical
proofs of strong nonlocality but again
we can consider a family of per hour a
parameterised family of measurements on
the on the equator and we get some nice
pictures like this and indeed we see we
can again observe where the Maxima are
and this gives us witnesses for strong
contextuality for these states some
competent some some of these sometimes
these explorations even lead one towards
seeing what might be true about some of
these things anyway okay so now what I
want to do is address the larger theme
which a sort of measure of contextual T
leads towards which is developing a
resource theory for contextual T so it's
worth saying a little bit generally here
physicists have developed a certain
genre of what they call resource
theories is I think quite interesting
for a logician since it has quite a sort
of logical character it started off with
entanglement which was widely perceived
as a basic resource for quantum
computation and ways of quantifying
entanglement as a resource and then some
more general picture of what a resource
theory should look like and by now it's
been extended to quite a few other
things been extended beyond quantum
mechanics into thermodynamics for
example where the issue of resources
is is obviously important and one of the
ideas is that so there's a formalism
that goes with this and some of the the
treatments of it that have happened
within the quantum information
foundations literature are quite quite
abstract and maybe quite interesting for
logicians to to look at one of the main
ideas is that you have various
operations and and you have so-called
free operations in particular so
operação operations which don't increase
or don't use the resource you're you're
focusing on should be regarded as free
and so that and that should be measured
by the fact that they don't increase in
the appropriate numerical measure the
amount of that resource that you care
about and this is a kind of test for a
suitable measure that it should be a
monotone with respect to these free
operations so that's another way of
testing this measure and also it leads
in an interesting direction as far as
trying to see what the resource theory
of contextual 'ti would look like
bearing in mind of course that they may
well be more than one useful measure of
contextual 'ti and time permitting I'll
say a bit about at least one other
possibility today so one that so as I
say one of these properties that a good
measure should satisfies it should be
monotone with respect to operations that
don't introduce contextuality and so the
direction we've gone in has also been
interesting because thinking about
operations leads to thinking what are
the natural operations on empirical
models and then one develops quite a
natural algebra of empirical models with
operations you can perform on them and
this algebra looks surprisingly similar
to process algebras of the kind of the
widely used in concurrency so there may
be another interesting connection there
so let's just think about empirical
models we're now going to think of the
measurement scenario as a kind way we
said it was a kind of syntax or
signature or we can think of it as a
poor a sort for the empirical model so
we have a natural operation of
relabeling where you'd you just kind of
take an isomorphic signature and
translate everything across to get from
one empirical model to another there's a
natural notion of restriction where we
go to a subpart of the of the
measurement scenario we throw away some
of the measurements and then we have
this restriction to the to the sub
measure and then a natural definition of
I mean the empirical model just does
what it what it did before on the sub
part that we've kept in the restriction
there's actually a more general
operation that subsumes both of these
where we pull an empirical measure back
along a map from on the on the
underlying so if we have a map from X to
X prime we can input an empirical model
over a measurement scenario with X Prime
back to an empirical model over the
width with a set of variables X amount
of special cases of that will give us
these two operations then there's so
this is all to do with the inputs as it
were the choice of measurements but then
we also have a natural coarse graining
operation that goes on the output side
so we can I mean again a special case of
this will be relabeling of outcomes but
if you imagine for example a map that
isn't injective it will be identifying
various outcomes so this is what
physicists like to call coarse graining
so we're sort of losing in from
observable information by by merging
together various outcomes and again
there's a natural way this act on the
empirical model so we're actually just
pushing the probability measures forward
along those along those maps induced
maps
then we have mixing which is an obvious
thing given to empirical models well I
mean you can always toss a coin and sort
of decide to to behave as one or the
other with that with that given
probability so we've already said that
empirical models are closed under convex
combinations so that gives us another
operation then we have a choice
operation which if we have two disjoint
sets of measurements is saying either
choose we can think of it as a sort of
controlled choice so we have a menu now
where either we choose a context from
the first one or a context from the
second one and if we choose from the
first one we do if we have the
probabilities exactly as in the first of
these models and if we choose from the
second just from the second so this is
actually very reminiscent of the
additive conjunction of linear logic
which is why we've written it with a
with an ampersand and finally there's
tensor which is taking two disjoint
models and now having them together and
you see now that the this is this is
just the sort of product opera really is
the product operation on simplicial
complexes so we take the disjoint union
of the vertices and then we say that
something is in the hyper graph if it's
the disjoint union of hyper edges from
the two things we started off with and
you see that the behavior on the model
we have both so any any assignment of
values here decomposes as a pair of
assignments on the two parts C and D
respectively and so then we we simply
take the product probability from the
two empirical models so just as just to
get some sense of how these things are
used we can build up any Bell any model
on a Bell type scenario
let's see a mixture of product tensor
products of choices of relabeling x' of
some very simple generator just with one
measurement so in a natural way we can
build up the non contextual models at
least for bail scenarios using these
operations and you can see also if
you're familiar with process algebra x'
as they're used in concurrency that
these these operations look quite
similar to the ones one finds there
there's one thing that's conspicuously
missing in this collection
anyone have any don't miss anything here
what do you mean by composition well so
there's two vague but to get the full
full marks for that but but just because
this is a commissions a kind of
composition they kinda parallel
composition well right so this is here
but what isn't here is a kind of
sequencing and so and that's a very
interesting thing but we're actually we
have a I mean the natural step to go I
mean the natural thing to add into this
would be a kind of prefixing of where
you first do some measurements and then
from the outcomes you get from those
measurements you may determine which
measurements to do next and this will
introduce causality into the empirical
months which is a very natural way of
extending the idea and an increasingly
causality is is sort of discussed
explicitly in the in the quantum
information world so that would be a
rich notion which would actually require
really I think some refinement of the
notion of empirical model itself
ok so we've introduced these operations
we now want to see how they behave with
respect to the contextual fraction
so I'm smiling here weekend because of
some painful memories of the middle of
last night when I was sweating over one
of these equations but not this one this
is easy so relabeling is is just going
to preserve it's just the trivial kind
of isomorphism it's going to preserve a
contextual fraction so you see
restriction is is is a so if you of
course yeah there's going to be a law
for the contextual fraction and a
complimentary law complementary
direction for the non contextual
fraction if you think about it if you go
to a smaller model than the
possibilities for contextual tea are
less the possibilities for non I mean
it's more likely to be non contextual
and that's so but so putting it this way
this is the the property that we get for
the restriction operation so this is a
typical case of being a monotone with
respect to a free operation and then
coarse graining is similar if you
conflate outcomes you're less likely to
detect contextual tea so again you again
this this monotone law and then mixing
so so you can see that it's actually a
the contextual fraction is a convex
function in the usual sense of real
functions it doesn't exactly preserve
convex combinations but it's you may
acquire well you get this this
relationship
and choice is straightforward so you
really have a discrete combination of
possibilities so the contextual fraction
is the maximum because if you had
contextual tea in one of the models then
you can get it here non contextual tea
is the is the minimum now the dangerous
one is the one relating to the tensor
product so let's say this is still under
discussion among the among the authors
of this paper in in progress but so
certainly we know that there's an
inequality that the for example the non
contextual fraction of the tensor
product is certainly greater than or
equal to the product of these things the
converse inequality is less clear at the
moment so then that remains to be seen
okay well anyway the what we see in
general is that the in a sensible
fashion if you think for example of in
terms of this discussion of monotones
and free operations if you take a tensor
product with a fixed non contextual
model that should not increase
contextual tea the inequality that we do
know to hold is already enough to tell
us that it is a sensible monotone in
that in that sense so free free
operations are are respected and similar
interpretations apply to the other
operations okay so now i want to say a
bit about quantifying quantum advantage
how the measure of contextual tea could
play a role in calibrating how much
advantage we can get over what can be
achieved classically for a given task
and this although this is kind of just
it seems that there's a promising
direction here so what we want is to use
the contextual fraction to quantify
advantage in various tasks so the
general form for results of the kind
we're looking for is the greater the
violation of the classical bound that we
want the more context
there has to be in the system in order
to achieve it so we're going to look at
one such result in terms of games and
the kind of games we'll look at are
fairly simple I mean they they greatly
generalize the XOR game that we
discussed in the in the first lecture
actually they could we can go much
further but the class will look at
subsume what have been quite widely
discussed in the quantum information
literature as what are called pseudo
telepathy games so let's look at this so
essentially we're going to take any
measurement scenario and specify a game
over it by just giving for each context
a set of winning conditions a set of
outcomes that we deemed to be winning so
we did so you can see how this
specializes to the XOR game for each
context we had this formula on the
outputs the XOR B which had to match up
with the the condition the conjunction
on the inputs so that can just be so we
had therefore an event in each row and
those events those sets of outcomes are
just what we're generalizing here so we
have this notion of game and then any
empirical model for the scenario can be
viewed as a strategy for the game so
again similar set up to how we describe
the XOR game we think of it as a game
against nature
so nature chooses a context and we're
going to assume that it does so you know
here for simplicity it does so uniformly
at random and given such a choice by
nature the empirical model is the the
opposing strategy and what it does is to
choose an outcome according to the its
distribution on the outcomes for that
context and then the success probability
of the strategy so we simply take the
sum over all these probabilities of
getting a winning outcome and we
normalize by the number of contexts so
here's that quantity again that we saw
so this gives us a probability and the
classical bound for the game is the
maximum success probability for any non
contextual strategy so that's sort of
the clear general notion of game for
arbitrary measurement scenarios and
empirical models and one advantage of
giving this relatively simple form of
game is that we can give a very clear
description or characterization of the
classical bound which is the which is
the maximum which is the maximum success
probability for any non contextual
strategy in terms of a generalization of
the kind of logical description of bill
inequalities that we we gave in a
particular case in the first lecture so
we look at this family of winning
conditions which are a family of sort of
subsets of the assignments or one over
each context and we say that it's K
consistent if the maximum cardinality of
a consistent sub family is K it's
obviously the the maximum possible
number is the number of contexts what it
means to be consistent is that there's
an assignment to all the variables that
appear in that sub family which is in
the which is in the winning set for
every context in the family so it's a
sort of localization of the idea of this
global assignment that we we've been
considering in in discussing contextual
so it's saying again how how far we can
get towards having such a global
assignment that's consistent and this is
an intrinsic property of the game viewed
as a set of winning conditions and now
we have by a sort of fairly simple
variation of the argument the actually a
very simple argument we gave in the
first lecture that the classical bound
for a K consistent game is just this
number K normalized by the number of
contexts so it's the same kind of
argument now we we can just derive a
sharper bound over this family of things
that it can't all be satisfied in terms
of this bound on the the maximum number
that can and actually if we take this
this more general form of inequality
that's sort of behind this then we get
in fact as one can prove a fully general
description of the bell inequalities
which we described abstractly earlier on
actually I was like yeah okay a suitable
measure of the so we could say then the
suitable measure of the non classic
allottee of a K consistent game is just
well I mean that the is that the I mean
you know the best thing would be the we
could really do everything classically
if the whole set of conditions was
consistent so that would be exactly the
maximum number would be this cardinality
of the of the M of the measurement of
the set of contexts and the difference
is the gap where the the non classic
allottee arises probably we should
normalize this by the cardinality of M
and actually that's pretty much going to
appear in this in this
anyway so here's a result which follows
fairly straightforwardly from the the
result we had about violation of the
normalized violation the bill
inequalities and relating that to the
contextual fraction so here's a result
that does give this quantitative
relationship between the contextual
fraction for a given empirical model
thinking of it as a strategy and the and
how well we can do in playing a given
game so we have two parameters here the
game and the empirical model so we're
given the game a set of winning
conditions were given a strategy so we
have a well-defined success probability
for this strategy and obviously then a
failure probability and then the
relationship is that this this ratio
here the this ratio here is is bounded
by the contextual fraction so what
that's saying is it for example fixing
the game so we have this level of
hardness this Mooji you remember that's
just this difference here so if we so
fixing this level of hardness if we want
to increase the success probability
which means to
decrease the failure probability I'm
sorry for writing it this way but it
seemed to be the neatest way of the
various options available so the so
increasing the success probability doing
better and that was reducing this
increasing the the difference here
requires increasing the contextual
fraction so in other words for a game
with a given level of difficulty the
higher we want the success probability
for a strategy to be the more contextual
the strategy has to be you could read it
oh you could fix the strategy and talk
about the game but I think this is the
most natural way of looking at it okay
so that does give a relation between the
contextual fraction and this fairly
natural task a nice point is that
something that looks different turns out
to have very much the same kind of
relationship indicating that there's
some general pattern here which may be
applicable to a range of tasks so I'm
not going to go into details here but
there there is a model of quantum
computation in fact the measurement
based quantum computation paradigm so
it's equivalent to the circuit model as
developed by Rosen Dorf briegel Dan
Brown and and others and a nice point is
that the this I mean so they as the name
suggests you that the computation
proceeds not by passing qubits through
the gates in a circuit but by performing
measurements and therefore it lends
itself to description in terms of the
kind of empirical models we've been
studying and it's completely general its
equivalent to the circuit model so what
we can do is to is to sort of refine a
result proved recently by robert rousan
Dorf in this connection which is that
suppose we have and I'm not going to go
into the details of how this is set up I
mainly want to make the point that the
structurally this looks exactly like
this result here so we have so the point
is we have a we have an empirical model
with a little bit of extra machinery
which can be viewed as computing a
boolean function and we can measure the
level of difficulty of the boolean
function by how far it is from being mod
to linear sort of Hamming distance
metric from the nearest mod to linear
function now obviously mod two linear
functions are easy to compute and we
don't need any context reality to
compute those essentially the
measurement based model mixes the sort
of quantum part or the or that other
part is described by the empirical model
with a sort of classical coprocessor
which is assumed to be able to do mod
two arithmetic anyway so that comes for
free I'm skipping the details but that's
the idea so so what this is saying is
that given a boolean function with a
level of difficulty measured by how far
it is from being mod to linear then the
same ratio is bounded in and given an
empirical model viewed now as a
measurement based computation or as
describing the resources used by a
measurement based computation for
computing this function so then it has a
well-defined success probability and
failure probability we get the same kind
of relationship with the contextual
fraction so the way we can read this is
saying the the higher you want the
success probability of computing your
function at a given level of difficulty
of being non linear that the higher the
contextual fraction has to be so I think
these are early steps but perhaps
promising towards developing a
quantitative theory of contextual 'ti as
a resource for exceeding classical
bounds okay I've got a final topic but I
don't want to take too much time on that
I just thought I'd briefly
show you something here so we talked in
the first lecture about the Delft
experiment and the miss and the NIST and
Vienna experiments so actually this is
the basic table of data for the Delft
experiment so what you see in the
entries here are actual counts and over
several months of experiment with some
very impressive equipment actually the
Delft tests have a total number of 245
events it's not that many but the nature
of the technology was somewhat limiting
of course they did a careful statistical
analysis and so forth this is the NIST
experiment where you see the numbers are
very much bigger the thing to bear in
mind with NIST is that it's using
different different physical system and
different technology so it uses
photonics in a much more traditional way
but relying on the extremely high
efficiency photon detectors that have
been developed at NIST in the photon
detector kind of experiment you're sort
of deflecting photons through
interferometers beam splitters and
you're testing whether they show up at a
given point or not so if they show up
you get a click if they don't show up
you get no click so of course no click
is that that big is not saying I didn't
I didn't go there it's just saying
nothing I didn't detect that it's one of
the major loopholes was a detection
loophole and actually you see that the
data is heavily weighted towards the one
one column which is indeed the no click
column nevertheless they did a very
careful statistical analysis and I think
I'm certainly not casting any aspersions
on these experiments but it's very
interesting to see what these things
look like and also to note there exactly
compiling tables of the kind that we've
been discussing so this does relate
directly to what happens in these things
one feature of this of course these are
frequencies
and we know that data is noisy so one
interesting point though is that these
things are actually I mean according to
the definitions if you just took these
these relative relative frequencies as
probabilities and you just took these to
be probability distributions that they
would violate the no signalling
principle that we've mentioned this is
just a fact about experimental data so
it's an interesting question what you do
about that and their various possible
reactions to it let me just mention
briefly that's something that we we've
looked at a bit and actually ran over on
this data is to do something very
similar conceptually to what we what we
did with the contextual fraction which
is to ask how no signaling is the data
and take the largest no signaling part
of the data and use that and one can do
that again using using linear
programming methods and then you get
this decomposition into the the part
that's no signaling and then as before
non contextual or strongly contextual
and then the the sort of rogue part
that's that is signaling so I wouldn't
yeah okay so I think we more thought
needs to be given to this but it's a
given that there is this situation and
that the question of what one does in
the presence of signaling which is
typically there in real noisy data it's
that's worthy of further study
well that's probably a sign I should
finish up let me just mention one final
topic and then I'll conclude I mentioned
that the contextual fraction is not the
only natural measure that one could use
I think it's possibly the most natural
and certainly one of the main candidates
but let me mention an intriguing but
clearly different measure and we still
haven't figured out the relationship
precisely between this measure and the
contextual fraction so here's a here's a
result which holds quite generally which
says that in a sense you can always get
a well you can get a quasi classical
source provided you're willing to enter
the strange world of negative
probabilities in other words if you ask
not for a probability measure on the
global assignments of values to all the
variables but a signed measure then then
you can always get such a global section
and notice that this is sort of an
appeal to a hypothetical entity as with
all such things the actual empirically
observed probabilities are always
honest-to-goodness probabilities
non-negative numbers summing to one the
point is behind the scenes we would be
invoking a signed measure the issue of
how we could possibly interpret these
things I mean actually it's been a
classic topic of discussion in in the
quantum literature Dirac Fineman we can
there are and others have discussed this
issue and some ideas we know in another
paper with Adam Brandenburger for a
possible kind of at least simulation of
this kind of thing but at any rate
that's not the point I want to make here
the point is there is always a
well-defined quasi hidden variable model
using signed measures using negative
probabilities and moreover by the way it
can be efficiently compute
because you just take the the linear
program that we have before for deciding
whether a model was contextual and you
remove the non negativity constraints or
all you have is a system of linear
equations and you just have to check you
know which one can do using a
dimensionality argument that that system
of linear equations always has a
solution
so it's efficiently you can have
computed efficiently and based on that
we can define a measure by how far it's
necessary to deviate from a standard
probability distribution to get a global
section so we have this weird thing that
may have negative numbers in it but how
far did we have to go away from being a
standard probability distribution in
order to get that as a natural way of
measuring that so we call that the the
negative probability measure
and actually this can be computed
efficiently as well the trick is to
split the the measure into two parts the
sort of the in the usual way of a sine
measure you decompose into the positive
part of the negative part and you can
compute it by by it you can compute the
optimal one by a linear program in much
the same way as what we've seen
previously so an obvious question is how
does this measure relate to the
contextual fraction and we have some
ideas about that but a general at the
moment there's no general account of the
description so I think it's an
intriguing possibility okay
so I'll stop there Thanks any quick
questions logic like your first term in
q2 probability theory we're going find
distributions and so on to explain for
instance there are the not sure about
explain the you here you United when you
bullet Y is the classical model so that
that's what acting like yes I see what
kind of weird logic with that
you know I'm personally I'm personally
not not shopping for a weird logic but
but there is there is a nice SoCo
hakushi de who's also been contributing
to this work has developed a logic of
contextual inference which in a paper in
this year's iCal about this week and the
point there is that suppose you have
this situation where you have local
consistency but global inconsistency is
there a natural way of constraining the
inference system so that the whole thing
doesn't crash and he has what he calls a
sort of inchworm logic because you not
sure I can explain if I equals that but
it's this sort of the thing that the
coils itself up and then them anyway so
it's so it's so it's sort of you have
inference you have turnstiles that are
indexed by context in a suitable way and
so you can propagate inferences where
it's safe to do so but you don't
actually reach these these
contradictions so that one that might be
I'm not sure that's what you're after
but that really not that difficult
any other questions
that's break for lunch can identify
Tasha stop we will give a group for the
party